欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来重点讲一下关于如何去发布优质的产品
发布一个4.9分高质量的好产品
一个好的产品的标准是怎么样的呢
第一个就是内容准确
因为我们发的内容越准确
那么客户搜索和匹配的准确性就越高
那么我们的转化就会更好
第二个就是属性完整
属性越完整, 客户搜索到我们产品的概率就越大
第三个就是价格阶梯要合理
价格阶梯越合理
那么客户想要发行盘咨询的
欲望就更大
而且价格阶梯要设置是平台的基本规则
如果我们没有价格阶梯
那么所获得的流量的权益就会有所下降
第四个就是物流合理
我们在使用物流模板的时候一定要设置合理
如果我们的物流价格太高
或者是物流选择线路不合适
那么都会影响我们的流量的转化
比如说你的物流太贵
那么是不是客户就没有办法直接下单
或者客户就不想跟你进一步的交流
所以这四个板块内容都非常重要
接下来我们来进行实操演练一下
首先我们打开后台
我们可以看到
我们去发产品
我们可以在这里去发产品
新发一个产品
也可以在这里去发一个产品
我们也可以根据我们同样的品类去
发布一款类似的产品
发布类似的产品呢
其实我们里面的很多内容
只需要做适量的修改就可以了
这是发布类似的产品
我们就不讲发布类似的产品了
那么我们来讲
新发布的产品
首先
首先第一个
你要选对你的
所要发的类目
比如说我选这个类目
或者是你不知道类目
你可以在这里通过关键词去搜索
通过关键词去搜索
无论哪个行业都是一样
你要选中你的类目之后
确定你要发的产品
类型是发RTS产品
还是说发定制产品
那么我这里就以RTS产品为例
首先我们选了RTS
点击进来之后
就是一个新的产品
这个是类目
你选择的类目
还有就是产品的类型
这些标题
就是我们之前已经在表格中做好的标题
直接复制进来
标题
K产品关键词
K1, K2, K3
都要在这里全部填上
我们已经整理好的关键词
把这三个都要填写
三个他们是不一样的
所以说你要把这三个填写出来
不一定说你的标题都是要128个字符
我们的标题组合跟关键词的组合
你可以按照我们之前讲的方法
我这里就随意的做个案例
这样的话这个是产品分组
就是你自己店铺里面的产品的分组
你怎么分
你要把它归类到哪一个组别
你可以自己去分
就是原厂第一班来说
我们这里是写中国的
那么你就直接写中国
那么这里省份你就填你们自己的省份就可以了
品牌的话你填你自己的品牌
如果没有品牌的话你就
直接写
直接写写一些
跟产品相关的关键词就可以了
定制logo
还有加产品词
你可以这样写
也可以写其他跟产品相关的词
关键词就可以了
型号这里可以填
你们公司的型号也可以
填国际通用的型号
比如说你的产品是国际通用的
那么你就填
国际通用的型号
因为这些型号
也是可以给你带来流量的
这些什么
类型的话
你根据你的实际产品的情况去填写
那这里我建议的话
比如说你的类型
这个是服装的
但是你的类型可能也有很多种
那么你在
整个店铺中
每一种类型
我建议你都要覆盖到
也就是这个链接发这个类型
下个链接发另一个类型
为什么呢
因为这些类型
当客户在
搜索的时候
他有些时候
平台是会根据这边这些属性来进行一个类型来进行一个
筛选的懂了吗
比如说客户勾选了一个
比如说如果客户勾选了一个
类型
那么你的店铺都没有这种类型的那么你的整个店铺都没有概率被
系统
捉取来展示
也没有办法给到客户看
所以说
这里的类型我建议的话是你多种类型都要发
产品特性的话你
所有的都要发
要满足条件的所有都要发
比如说这个供应商类型的话如果是你RTS的话就要选下面这个
如果你是做定制的话那么你就要选择OEM这个服
材质的话你就要选择具体的
产品的材质
工艺的话如果你的是RTS的
已经有明确的工艺的话那么你只需要选择一个合适的工艺就可以了
如果你是
定制
类的产品的时候
那么你只要能够做的工艺都可以勾选上
那么你这个产品就能够覆盖大量的工艺
当客户搜索
某个工艺加产品词的时候那么你这个产品就有机会
获得曝光
性别这些肯定是按照
实际的来填
啊设计也是按照实际的来填季节啊这种款式
这些全部都是按照实际的这个你们能不能做能做的话就直接写
支持
但是如果无论你能不能做我都建议你写
支持7天快速打压
这毕竟是比较好的一个展示出来
这些都是带信号的都是必填的
那么这些你都要自己去选
这些客重也是一样的
你能够
做的客重
如果你是定制产品你能够做的客重
全部覆盖完
我这个我这里举的都是例子
你可以对照着你的来
一个个的去
做
这个属性的话
我们要把
客户最关注的点
最关注的内容
写下来
这些就按照
客户最关注的那些内容把它写下来
罗列出来
特别是要让客户看到他想看到东西
因为这里的话你看
我们写的
自定义属性都会在这些地方展示
如果你写的越好
他是不是看你详情页的时候
就能够
清晰的看到你所要填写的内容了
是吧
那么我们这样
都填
建议把你建议你把这
十个全部填满我这里就不填满了
这也是
这里的这些你都要
去填满
我们这些全部都填上
我点的这个的话是智能
智能填写的因为之前我发过产品所以说
系统给我推荐智能
这尺寸的话也是一样的
无论哪个行业都有
还有这里
你可以是
选颜色也可以直接是
选择你自己的产品的图片
或者是从图片银行里面选
按照你的需求去选
比如说选一个
这种颜色的
直接以
款式
来进行展示
就可以了
这样的话更加直观
客户看到了更加清晰
因为这里的
图片
这里的图片就是
我们所说的
这里的图片看到了吗
这里的图片
你看产品的展示图都在这里
这里对应这里
接下来
就是你的尺寸表啊
各种如果你是你能做的你就显示出来
如果不能的话就不显示
从
上传图片
你可以上传
6张
你可以是本地上传
在你电脑上上传
也可以在你先上传到
呃后台的图片银行也可以
你看我们先检测一下他是1.8是吧, 诸读视频
有诸读视频的一定要全部悬上一定要全部悬上
因为有诸读视频的话
你的视频是优质的那么你获得的流量的权益就会更多
是倾斜流量
详情页也就是详情页是我们的下面这部分盘款这部分盘款
这些就是详情页
我们
这个框里面填写的内容就是下面的这些
如果我们
填写
这个的时候如果我们没有模板我们需要提前去做好模板先
再来这里一键导入就可以了
这里支持模板的导入
比如说我们用的话
现在都用智能编辑
因为智能编辑
能够有营销的优惠券还有折扣这些内容展示在里面
同时呢我们展示产品
的画面就更加的直观
而且它的样式非常多
所以说我们要选的智能编辑我要编辑
编辑了之后呢
我们就直接选个基础模板
基础模板
这里面这些内容就是由你自由的排版了
你看这些内容都有你自由排版
你可以把这些删掉
把这些删掉
这些都可以删掉
你看这些导航
我把这些删掉
内容删掉
上移
下移
复制
这复制
这些都可以
都可以操作
板块的话我们可以在这里看
按住它
拖过来
左肩按住拖过来
它的位置就随便你调了
这位置都可以随便你调
按照你的需求去装修
图片
你可以选择这些样式
你需要哪个就按住拖过来
按住拖过来就可以了
表格也是
都可以
这些
3D 预压都可以
这些都可以自己自己做
排版好了之后你可以在这里
另存为自定义模板
另存为自定义模板的话你要
把这个存为比如说我存为我把它命名
命名成一个模板通用的模板把它
做好分组
分组了之后他到时候就会在
自定义模板这个板块出现了
你看就在
自定义模板
完整版本
你看完整版本
比如说你点这个完整版本
点这个完整版本的话他就会跳出来
你把这些
全部删完之后
比如说你把这整块
板块全部删完了
你点个完整版本那么这整个模板就直接出来出来之后你点击
保存完成编辑
那么这样是不是就出现了
这个详情页就完整的在这里展示了再检测一下
4.6分已经到4.6分了看到没有
就
其价格的话比如说这种你按键卖你就填按键卖按批卖就按批卖
这种的话你要填你能做到的
就可以了
这个价格也是按照
接近实际你可以比实际的低一点点
但是如果是你卖RTS的话这个链接的话那么你一定是按照
正常的价格的
毕竟客户是可以直接下单的但是你
如果是定制的链接呢
那么你可以稍微低点是没有影响的
那么这些尺寸都是这些可以不用边去边写这些东西
如果是你RTS的话填写
数量啊起定量啊都要按照你能做的去填写就可以了
如果是你
定制的产品的话那么你就直接
这些都可以相对来说
小一点但是定制的产品的话建议起定量不要太低
因为你做定制的肯定是相对来说
要满足这些起定量你才能做的
所以说你就按照实际的能做的来填写
这相规呢如果是你按照一箱一箱的产品来卖那么你就要在这里
自己去设置一个
相规
长宽高体积重等等这些你要自己去算把它的
重量
尺寸算出来按照实际的物流价格去填写就可以了
这个就是
每个商品的长宽高包含包装的
尺寸一定要填写清楚
因为这里就直接涉及到你的物流费用
涉及到你的
样品的物流费用
都是从这个里面算的
根据这个长宽高体积
以及他的毛重来计算的
这两个哪个高
就用哪个来计算哪个贵就用哪个来计算所以说
这里填写一定要
准确
甚至你要比准确的高一点填高一点点
因为
避免你的物流费
亏损
那么这里的属性的话我们按照实际的填你是什么样的产品就要按照这种
模式去填你想
就按照这种模式去填你们的对应的产品就可以了
物流模板呢我们是提前设置好的那么你就选择你
这个产品对应的物流模板就可以了
填完之后呢他下面会有这些
国家的物流的详情展示
他会有一个
价格
你看到没有
你去看一下这个价格是否合理
如果这个价格太高
或者是说已经超过了市场的价格很高那么客户是很
难去下单的因为你物流太贵了他不可能主动下单了
所以你如果是
非常多巡盘或者是非常多的点击访客但是就没有没有订单的时候你要来看一下你的物流
费用是不是太贵
物流的线路是不是太少
以及你的价格起定量是不是都不
不合理你在优化产品的时候
就可以去优化产品
的价格起定量还有他的物流模板这些都需要
优化这个样品的我们通常都是要设置样品的
比如说设置一个样品那么你就要在这里填写完你的样品模式
填你的样品价格是多少
保存
价格的话
你看我们就把这些
水盘填完之后就是
如果你的链接是定制的产品那么这个样品还是可以下单的所以你在
设置这个物流的
内容的时候一定要写准确因为这个
样品是按照那个尺寸和重量来计算的
一定要填写清楚
这些就按照实际的填你
把这些增加你可以在这里增加你按照你实际的需求去增加填写数量
这里是不支持, 这里都要填支持
这两个都填支持
你要国家的话我们就选去选
满足
我们目标市场的10个国家, 也就是我们在这里选的国家
就是我们想做的市场
这些都是我们想做的市场
填写这些并不是代表着你只给这些国家看, 而是说你的这款产品更偏向这些国家
那让系统知道你的
产品偏向这些国家
就这样
那么填完了4.6分
4.6分是哪里不合理呢
这个产品是4.5分跟我们刚才讲的那个4.6分
他的
问题在哪里呢?首先我们从这一边
去看它会有具体的
形式告诉我们具体的问题在哪里
有些时候
这里全部通过了
但是呢
它还是4.6到4.7分
那么我们怎么样去优化呢?
比如说我们要去看
我们
所有的信息填写完整没有
你看我们这里显示
产品详营业质量
不加,那么这里你看
太过于简单
不利于买家深入了解产品的特征, 建议你在这个板块丰富内容
用表格图片文字等内容信息来呈现
那么这种情况呢我们就去
信里面去编辑
把这个全是清空了
我们试着换一个模板看看怎么样
比如说我换这个模板随便换一个模板
保存
这个模板里面是不是又有图片又有表格等等
素材点击检测一下
马上得4.9分了是吧
所以说我们要按照他的提示去优化就可以了
图片表格
等等信息都要按这个
都要按照这个
思路去做
我们这里比如说我用这个图
也是可以得到
如果我减去三个图呢
看他还是不是
4.9分
他还是4.9分是吧
所以说你就按按照这种思路
通常
达不到4.9分的原因就在于
产品的
主图以及
相营业的问题
就这两个板块最大
还有另一个就是你样品
没有设置
也可能没有得到4.9分
这三个板块你重点去分析就可以了
还有
最后一个就是物流
也就是四个板块直接决定着你是不是4.9分
你就按照这
几个思路去
检查就可以了
物流的话设置我们来看一下
物流我们在这个物流模板里面
我们要点击进去
比如说你要新建一个
物流的话那么你就在这里添加一个物流
添加物流
这是你自己命名的物流模板的名称
然后就是发货的邮编
就是你公司的邮编吧
地区的邮编
点完之后呢就进来进来到这里
这里的各种快递很多种
你就去选择你们能够使用的
而且你们能够承接的那些物流就可以了
这里面去修改你们
需要做的国家
哪些国家你们能够运过去的
那么你就做
哪些国家就可以了
这里溢价建议全部统一120溢价
为了避免物流费用
太
容易亏损
所以说120
这是平台规定
最高是120溢价
所以说建议的话你不要超过120
一定要不要超过120
你也可以在最高是120
如果你的
120了
你觉得物流费还是太便宜了
容易亏损的话你就在这个位置
就在你的产品
这里
尺寸
跟重量
这里提升数据
一点重量加他的尺寸
那么在
计算的时候
整个物流的费用就会
提升起来了
这样的话你就不会亏损
所以说按照这个逻辑
当然你也可以自选
自己的物流
如果你们有自己的物流的话也可以在这里改
自己按照这个
思路去写就可以了
就按照正常来去写
既抛笔的话
按照
你们的品类
来选择就可以了
通常
基本都是5000
保障国家的话
一定要把这10个这些国家全部勾上
也就是你的
物流比如说这里选这些国家的时候是不是
你就把那些
这10个国家有相关的只要符合一个的都把它勾上就可以了
并不一定代表你每把这10个都勾上
你只要是这个物流板块里面有
这10个中的其中一个就可以了就满足这个平台的规则了
就按照这种思路去做
我们来看一下
我们产品详言页里面是不是有一个
营销板块
比如说这个折扣的还有这个优惠券的是吧
那么我们是在这里选的
自己
直接把它拖过来比如说我删掉这个我删掉这个
我们拖过来拖过来他就在这里了
他就在这里了这个位置你可以自由的调整
为什么我们一定要放一些优惠券呢
这样更有吸引力比如说客户点进这个优惠券的时候
他就会跳到一整个
链接里面比如说我这里试一下给你看
这里
客户就会有一个优惠券
你看看到没有这里就有一个优惠券
如果是你不设置的话这里就空空的就没有看得到
他如果是点你的这个优惠券的话
他进去之后比如说我这个是没有登录账号的
如果他登录的账号
那么他一点进去的时候
就是展示你很多优惠券里面的一些产品展示给客户
也就是客户又能够看到你的更多的产品得到的展示
这个板块设置的话
我们要在我们自己的后台
活动中心折扣
还有优惠券再打开
你只有这里设置了
你去设置
那么你设置了之后
生效了
这里系统就会自动的抓取数据进来展示了
你保存编辑完成保存编辑完成
就可以了
那么这个就是我们
PC的产品详细页
也可以是无线端的
你可以是同步过去的
也可以是单独编写的
都可以
这个按照你的需求去做就可以了
那么这个就是我们整体的产品发布
的一些方法
只要我们按照这个逻辑去把这几个
板块完整就可以了
4.9分
是很容易做得到的
如果得不到4.9分
那么大概率就是我刚才讲的那四个方面
出现的问题
你只需要去把那四个方面
优化好就可以了
这节课我们就讲到这里
如果你的
产品很多达不到要求
那么建议你现在可以去适当的优化
不一定要达到4.9分
但是你要达到4.5分
因为后期
优品的很多的权益
是在4.5分的产品
才拥有的权益
所以说
建议你
所有的产品都要想办法做到4.5分以上
是更好的
如果你得不到4.9
那么就4.5吧
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
到这里,下节课,我们再见